all right baby
baby uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally originally from
loudoun tennessee
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents when you were kids
um
no my dad was always in prison and my
mother
she was a prostitute and a crackhead she
was there but unfortunately she was
you know i'm saying not really there
like she should have been so
i pretty much grew up raising my little
brother my little sister from
the age of four up
how was your charlotte my childhood um
when i was growing up was pretty crazy
it's pretty wild pretty sad
pathetic not having a mom or a dad you
know having to sell drugs and
led on to doing drugs and raising kids
never got to be a child but
um all in all i say kind of made me the
person i am today so i can't say it was
that bad
because i don't think i'm that bad of a
person what kind of stuff went on it
i've seen everything from from
drug use to gang banging to people
getting killed
to
[Music]
people get raped i've been raped
all type of [ __ ] what age did this
happen for you
um what age was i raped yeah
um my first time i was raped it was at
the age of 14.
in knoxville tennessee yeah in the hood
by a grown man
it's a very very rough childhood yeah
pretty much
and what age did you leave home i'm all
left home at the age of 16 and moved out
on my own
and what about your younger siblings um
at that point
i had already been through states
custody and my younger siblings were
living
with my aunt and uncle my mom's sister
so
they had already gone to them
and i grew up in the system in foster
care and group homes
in and out of it until until i ged out
at
17. and where'd you go then um
then i went i left state and i went to
south carolina with my baby's father
so you have one child um i have a
three-year-old daughter
and then i'll have the child that i'm
pregnant with how far along are you
six and a half months six and a half
months
are you raising your um no unfortunately
my aunt and uncle that have my brother
and sister when i was growing up they
have her because
it was a foul [ __ ] my baby daddy beat on
me and kidnapped her and
lied to some police about some weed
paraphernalia they found in the house
they got her taken away
so she's now three and almost four and
she's living
with them in tennessee yeah and you're
living on skid row
yes you came out to california when um
about two and a half three weeks ago oh
so you're brand new
yeah i was actually in vegas for the
past three years
so i was in vegas and then i came out
here
and the dude i came out here with that i
was supposed to be dating he
put his hands on me stole my phone left
me on figure were in 63rd because i
didn't want to sell [ __ ] for him so
then i just i don't know i just been out
here ever since
and is he the father of your no my
baby's father
is in vegas in prison yeah he gets out
in november
so you're using drugs um not
really now i was when i first found out
i was pregnant all i do right now is
smoke weed
but i'm trying you know what i'm saying
to stay away from that i don't
i don't really want to lose this baby so
what was your drug before um
i've been on everything i've been on
pills on meth on
cocaine i tried heroin once but i didn't
do
that wouldn't you know i'm saying my
thing so
but mainly methamphetamines was a big
one
and pain pills painkillers
was a big that was what i started off
doing
when i was doing it i was all shooting i
was shooting up hella bad
and then february 14 no february 16
2017 i lost my mother
while i was two months after i came to
vegas and i got a phone call on
facebook video chat and then four days
after that
on the day of her cremation and her
memorial
they found her father my grandfather
dead in his bedroom floor and i viewed
his body on facebook
so i i was doing dope pretty bad then
meth and then i found out that i was
pregnant uh
in march so i stopped you know i'm
saying pretty much everything i think
i've done drugs twice since i felt that
i was pregnant just being you know hella
depressed
but other than that i really don't want
to lose my baby so
i'm pretty much what you've been doing
for money
um right i've been broke since i've been
here honestly
i've been trying to get you know ebt
through the food stamp office the the
gr or whatever it is they haven't done
nothing for me out here so i just been
pretty much living off of nothing yeah
do you date guys sometimes for money no
i
m like i said when my i was younger my
mom was a prostitute
so i kind of like
have strong feelings toward prostitution
but in the way
like i can't knock nobody's hustle
because i didn't sell drugs i didn't i
don't solicited my body before
when i was younger i didn't you know
what i'm saying i didn't did a lot of
stuff
so right now my my
feelings towards prostitution with me
being raped several times growing up
with my mom seeing seeing my mom go
through stuff
i just i don't know i don't trust these
guys especially out here
the west coast is a lot different yeah
so you've been homeless for how many
years now um i was homeless in vegas for
about a year off and on and then when i
came out here two weeks ago i've been
homeless since then
you've had rough things happen to you
yeah i've been raped drug
robbed kidnapped by truck drivers woke
up in
the back of civil trucks in other states
you know
drugged to the point where i don't
remember three or four days at a time
woke up black and blue
a bunch of bad stuff like i just i don't
know
i just don't like
i have a bad trust issues with anybody
man or a woman
you have any friends no
do you talk to your daughter i do
occasionally um my aunt and uncle they
couldn't have children
so they kind of took when they got my
daughter she was at a
young enough age that they felt like
this was going to be their child
so now she's four years old almost and
and they're raising her so she called in
mommy and daddy but she know who i am
but i do talk to her it's just kind of a
pain in the ass to get my aunt and uncle
to
my little sister i have to call my
little sister that lives with them in
order to talk to her
so your plan for the baby is to do what
you'll be homeless when you have the
baby right
hopefully hopefully i can get some kind
of like housing through
this state out here i've heard they're
pretty good about it but if not i mean
right now my options are kind of open
and i'm kind of back and forth
with it like i want to keep my baby but
at the same time i don't want to be
homeless with my baby and i want my baby
to have a life that i can't you know i'm
saying i can't give them right now so
i have to put like adoption up for a
decision
i guess that might have to be an option
i don't know but right now my
my main goal is to try to get some kind
of housing or
section 8 i don't know something
something out here
do you feel like your your childhood
that was
far from ideal kind of led to the next
generation of the same kind of
problems with you and your children in a
way i feel like a lot of it was
well some of it was my fault but in a
way i feel like a lot of it was more
my parents fought for not raising me how
i should have been raised
so i don't think that i had like
the knowledge or the anything
to to be able to raise my child the
correct way
you guys are better off with your aunt
than with you i feel like my daughter is
definitely better off with my aunt
because when i had her three years ago
i definitely was not in no kind of
position i was
strung out on drugs i was selling drugs
i was cooking meth
it was like it was all bad
so i feel like i wasn't ready as much
now
or as much then as i am now i'm a little
bit more ready even though i'm kind of
like
homeless and i'm not in like a stable
position to be ready but i'm more
mentally stable
how old are you 26. well i'll be 26 in
march
how did you get out here to la um well i
was
i was dating the dude and he was
supposedly a pimp
but you know my feelings against
prostitution he knew
you know what i'm saying so i don't know
when we got out here
he just kind of turned on me and he took
me down to 63rd and figure and tried to
make me sell [ __ ] and i was like no and
he you know
beat on me out there on the street and
stole my phone
and left me just left me out there so
i ended up walking back to downtown i
was actually out in l.a last year i came
to um
cali and i was in fresno for a while and
then i came
i ubered la from fresno and i was out
here but i like i had been through skid
rows so
i knew the area but i didn't i've never
like
really been you know out here so i
didn't know
but i walked back down here to la to
skid row
and since then i just been down here
i've been trying to get help nobody want
to help
they don't want to give me no food
stamps no nothing
yeah you're going from one tough
neighborhood to another yeah pretty much
i just i don't know
i don't know do you think going to live
with your aunt
could be an option no my family doesn't
really
they don't really [ __ ] with me at all
because of
my mom like my mom did them real dirty
and i was like my mama's baby i was her
best friend growing up
she was never my mom she was always my
best friend so
my little brother and my little sister
when they went to live with my aunt
uncle when we got put into states
custody or taking it to the
yeah to stage custody or whatever and
they went with them and i went into the
system
then my family kind of like my aunt
has been like the golden child my mom
was the black sheep so
they don't [ __ ] with me like they
[ __ ] like
i can't call my aunt be like hey can you
western you need me twenty dollars but
if my sister call and say hey i need a
thousand dollars she gonna be on that
[ __ ]
so they don't they kind of just disown
me
just because of the [ __ ] that my mom did
my mom used to rob him she was real bad
strong got on drugs too
so she used to rob him call him lie you
know
call him only when she wanted to be
bonded out of jail [ __ ] like that
so they kind of like put that on me
because i was her baby and i guess they
think that i was going to be like her
yeah so you're clean
from drugs um i mean i can't say i'm
clean because i have used
a few times since i found that i was
pregnant and there are days that go by
that i just feel like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] i want to get high but
then i got to think about the bigger
picture like
i got this little this little creature
in me that's growing and it can feel all
the [ __ ] that i'm feeling and it could
like if i get high this baby gonna be
20 times higher because it's new to this
baby
so i mean i can't say that i'm
completely clean because
if i wasn't pregnant i could guarantee
you i'd be out here getting high
sometimes
there's i mean there's just days that i
just don't want to deal with the [ __ ]
you're living in a tent which is right
making it even harder i mean do you
do you see getting a job maybe and and
supporting yourself
if i had like an id i don't have nothing
because all my [ __ ] got stolen
everything i owned got stolen and
so you get an id you get a job you get
off the street um that would be
definitely a possibility maybe a stable
that would be definitely something i
would
you know i'm saying be interested in
doing even an undertake
under the table job i can do something
like that any kind of income
i just want to do better i don't want i
don't want this baby to live the life
that i had to live
let alone the life that i showed my
daughter
at that young of age you know i'm saying
i want to just
i want to be something i don't want to
leave my kids my mom passed away at 44
years old i'm only 25.
so i don't want my daughter to be you
know what i'm saying across the map and
get a phone call on facebook messenger
video chat like oh your mom's dead here
view her body real fast because we're
about to burn her
that's how they did me
well yeah because i mean the the
the chain of yeah it's like the family
you just
it's [ __ ] up the events repeat
themselves generation after generation
right it's up to you to kind of step in
and change the direction of your life so
that changes the direction of your
child's life
all right baby well thank you so much
for talking with me and and good luck
with with your life and your baby
thank you
you